[Music]
when a young man creates a device that
amplifies paranormal activity within his
home he unwittingly unleashes spirits
with evil intent our house is the new
Netflix horror movies based on the book
ghosts from the machine by Matt Osterman
and throughout this video I'll be
discussing the film's plot in full
detail as well as its ending there will
be heavy spoilers and it may be worth
skipping this video for now if you're
yet to see the film but without the way
I'm definition and I ruin it so you
don't have to we follow Ethan a young
genius that believes that he and his
friends have created a device that will
generate wireless energy codenamed Eli
the wireless electricity application
will make electrical wires a thing of
the past
there'll be no more need to run to the
charger when your phones are one percent
or two even plug in your laptop so you
don't miss any of these terrible Netflix
movies yeah anyway the experiment fails
and the trio decide to abandoned it when
Ethan's parents are killed in a car
accident early on in the film the
teenager becomes a guardian to his two
younger siblings
Ethan chose to carry out the experiment
instead of picking up a family member
which led to his parents crash so he
carries a lot of the guilt on his
shoulders struggling with money and the
other stresses that come with parenting
Ethan retries the experiment within his
home and soon discovers that he and his
family are able to communicate with the
dead through the device after leaving it
running for a prolonged period his
younger siblings begin to communicate
with what they believe are their
deceased parents and inexplicable
occurrences begin to happen within the
home this confirms to all family members
that the device can indeed contact the
dead and they begin operating it often
and foolishly even going so far as to
improve its capabilities at the spirits
requests this allows the spirits to
attempt to drown Rebecca and a dark
female shadow appears within the house
Ethan's neighbor who possesses psychic
abilities notices that there is an aura
around the house and informs the
protagonist that his former partner
killed herself within the home and that
he has been seeing visions of ever it's
through this conversation that Ethan too
covers that the device has reached
beyond the house we learn that the name
of the dark spirit that inhabits Ethan's
house is called Alice and that she was a
girl that mysteriously disappeared
police believed that a man named henry
gifford had abducted and murdered her
though there was no evidence ever found
it's at this point that Rebecca is led
into the basement by a small Patch doll
that leads to her being pulled into a
chest
Rebecca awakens to find herself in a
room beyond a large bolted door though
it's never explicitly stated a Captain
Obvious here drew the conclusion that
this is what initially happened to Alice
as well
Rebecca was initially almost drowned in
the bathtub because she reminded the
spirits of Alice and this is why they
coveted her when attempting to destroy
the machine Ethan is stopped by his
neighbor who just wants the soul of his
dead wife to live on but Ethan manages
to convince him otherwise this
highlights how addictive the machine
could become should it be mass marketed
and it is sort of be careful what you
wish for allegory that warns us of the
danger of Ouija boards and alike ether
manages to destroy the machine but in
the end we witnessed that the dollar
lured Rebecca has been brought with them
even though she left it in the house
we watched the doll peering out from a
box which of course symbolizes the
entrapment of Alice and Rebecca and
showcases that Henry was not actually
defeated he was merely disabled this
highlights that the spirits are now
fully in our world and stalking the
family with their eyes still set on
Rebecca a lot of the motives in the film
are carried out because of guilt and
longing to recover with the families
deceased parents as someone who's dealt
with a lot of loss this year I could
definitely relate to the longing like
the characters faced and wondered if I
would be corrupted by such a machine in
the same way that Ethan's neighbor was
the film subscribes to the theory that
electromagnetic energy levels allow
someone to live on after their death
Einstein famously stated that energy
cannot be created or destroyed and that
can only be transferred from one form to
another this means that once we die the
energy from our body is changed to
another form but does not dissipate it's
a theory that if correct would allow us
to live on forever
and adds weight to the fact that goes to
me indeed exists personally it's
something I've always been heavily
interested in and the piece offers an
original take on
may be able to reconvert the energy
should a device that enables that be
created it's great that they decided to
include a scientific method on how to
contact ghosts as these have been
developed through the centuries however
none have had any substantial merit our
house separates itself from the typical
original horror films that the streaming
service showcases due to its soundtrack
this ATSs music really adds an
atmosphere to the work that piqued my
interest throughout however the film
itself suffers from some slightly poor
pacing and slower moments that make it
slightly dull and mundane ethan fails
the experiment twice and spends a lot of
time discussing how it may work instead
of it actually working to me this felt
like needless padding and I think the
film would have flowed better should he
have been successful on the second
attempt and spent less time delivering
exposition our house has a great third
act and definitely should have been the
aesthetic that the film chose to lead
with I thought the film had some great
cinematography to it and the stylish
design of Eli had a futuristic yet retro
feel to it that felt something akin to
Knight Rider and Doctor Who as a whole
lo it failed to really deliver and was a
slight disappointment for me so what are
your thoughts on our house did you enjoy
it and what did you take from the ending
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of the
Netflix original chilling Adventures of
Sabrina at linked at the end of this one
this is a channel for people who were
heavy into horror so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace I don't know why they didn't
have this song our house by madness in
it just seems that a massive messed over
tune this movie's just one massive
missed opportunity for playing our house
by madness dear me
[Music]